uh masayoshi uh you uh
you got the uh the exclusive interview
uh i remember polina telling me at one
point
she was like this has got to be the
number one interview that everyone wants
uh one how did you get them to agree to
do it and then two
tell us everything about that uh that
piece yeah so talking to masa yoshi-san
was like
top of my list for probably three years
um ever since the vision fund burst on
to the tech scene
and you know for those who aren't super
familiar like 100 billion dollar
fund to invest in tech companies
it was that's at a factor bigger than
we'd ever seen before
some of the biggest vc firms in the
world you know their aum is maybe 10
billion now
um but so 100 billion dollar fund
just to invest in these companies it was
just a massive impact right
and and we were talking about it the
whole tech world reporting world
we're talking about the impact of this
fund for good and bad but talking to
masa who's based in japan and doesn't do
a lot of interviews was really hard
i basically found out that he gave maybe
one english language interview a year
and so i just had to like be that
interview
at some point and and i tried you know
multiple times and failed
um but around the end of last year the
beginning of 2020 there were a lot of
doubts around softbank and the vision
fund
wework had obviously been a massive blow
up
and uber um its stock was not doing
great its shares were underwater for
from a sophomore standpoint
there was a lot of doubt so basically
what i did is i said
you know i am not going to be beholden
to any narrative
i am going to hear you guys out and if
there's a way
that softbank can still win here or that
moss is misunderstood
i i will like take that beginner's mind
and i will hear it out and i will try to
give you guys a fair shake
and i think my track record and
i guess my sales pitch were strong
enough
that they thought okay like we will try
that
and but i think it was definitely nervy
on both sides um and i did meet with
masa in march
right before everything shut down in new
york um it was really interesting
experience and interview and he was
much more unrepentant than i thought he
would be you know i had a bunch of
questions like
what have you learned from this or what
would you do differently
and for someone like him the answer was
kind of like my tactics might have been
wrong but my strategy is always right
and it's like that is you know that's
what's made him so successful
but it also is why i think the
criticisms can be fair too
so that was it was a trip um talking to
all the people in the south bank orbit
was a unique experience
it was extremely stressful but we were
really happy
you know with the story that we were
able to put together and i hope that
anyone in the audience who goes and
reads that story would think it's fair
look
at kind of why they're in in tough
straights but also how masa can sort of
always you know pull himself out of the
fire in the end
yeah when you met with them in person
was there any other takeaways that you
had
uh in terms of you know it takes a
special guy to uh on the way to pitch
somebody for a hundred billion dollars
to
literally say i think the story is uh
they were on the plane
and somebody showed them the deck and it
said a 30-year plan and he said add a
zero
right to it to make it a 300-year plan
yeah anyone who just
thinks that way is obviously very
different but what were some of the
takeaways from me to be a person getting
talked to
well first off masa is is a lot less um
imperial than i think he comes off as
part of that is because he has an
entourage he's based in japan
it's you go through so many hoops to
meet him you've kind of built him up
in your head but he's actually you know
a relatively
you know small smiling you know
unthreatening seeming man physically you
know just in like his
uh you know sweater and everything um
and and and he kind of walks
serenely surrounded by this
constellation
of like freaked out intense people
so that's kind of that was my first
impression is just that everywhere he
went it seemed like
he was totally calm and this is someone
that if you sat next to him at a
you know ramen place you could have a
beer with him but
all his handlers all his lieutenants no
you could not and they would not let you
get close to him
so that that was one i would say in
terms of how he speaks
he is definitely one of these big
picture folks like he'll speak
in big metaphors he'll speak in kind of
the arc of history
um as someone who studied history i
could appreciate that
but um some people love that
that he can just sort of fit together a
future you know
the technological future of the next 30
years into
a coherent narrative and that just
really resonates and then everything he
does is kind of fitting
the narrative for other people that is
just inflexible and like impossible to
actually do anything with like he could
say ai is going to have a bigger impact
on the world
than the you know microchip and you
could be like cool
that may be right like what does that
actually mean for us
in the day-to-day you know and and one
of the big things that i was trying to
understand was like
okay if he thinks that data and ai
are the future um what does that
actually mean for these companies like
can uber
actually benefit from that in any
meaningful way can doordash suddenly
beat all its competitors just because we
understand that data is important like
there are limits to what you can do with
data
and in fact like people are much more
mindful now about how their data is used
so i think for me the interesting thing
was that he has this like 40 000 foot
view of the worlds and and then he's
trying to apply it
you know on a company by company basis
and i think that's where things can
either go great or they can go really
badly
yeah was there any sense of um
maybe you talked about like him as a
person but any of the views that he held
where
uh you felt like he is uh either really
misunderstood
or people just have misconceptions like
he believes a but everyone thinks he
believes b
yeah i would say that he um
he sees um the power law
of investing i think just a little more
nakedly than a lot of vcs
um who who actually probably believe it
more in private than they would say
masa just believes that a lot of markets
are a winner take all market effectively
that one brand is just going to end up
crushing most of the others
and obviously that's true in some
industries it's not maybe not so true in
other industries
but i think that directionally he's not
as crazy as it seems
about that and so are you know are you
really overpaying in the short term
if all you're doing is trying to find
that outlier like winner take all market
i would say probably not as much as he's
sort of ridiculed for i think the
problem is where you
think that maybe a market is winner take
all and it's not and so you put a lot of
money into something
without it ever really being able to be
the breakout you know like like
hopefully there will continue to be
a lot of podcast companies and so if you
would just crazy valued
you know gimlet or wundery or whatever
like it will crush every other podcast
company
probably not going to be the case um the
other thing i would say is that i think
like
masa um is more self-aware than i think
a lot of people think like he's mind
he knows the criticism he's not like
some uh like
i don't know naive person who just like
doesn't understand
what people think about him i just don't
think he cares
and there is something to admire there
of just the person who like
knows that a lot of people doubt them
and just
sleeps well at night anyway like he was
like i was you know i asked him like
what do you think about everyone just
kind of like you know
making fun of the vision fund or
thinking like you're a crazy person for
what you're doing
and he was like oh i had it worse after
the dot-com bubble
he's like this is nothing i don't know
like if if
if i would feel that way but i did kind
of have to respect him for just being so
unperturbed
yeah well and i think the part that was
interesting is
uh i have to forget he was uh nobody he
became the richest guy in the world
lost it all and then i think he became
the richest guy in the world a second
time or came
close to it right and so he's kind of
had this uh
this very epic uh boom and bust cycles
personally
right and so i think that that does
probably harden you a little bit i think
it also like
you know i think it's weird for some
investors to have an investor
who doesn't seem to be motivated just by
like
hoarding money you know like like i
don't know if it's a gambler mentality
or what it is but like he
as you said he um claims to have been
the richest person in the world briefly
during the dot-com bubble
everything was so crazy that that's very
hard to to
perfectly confirm um but yeah this he
lost softbank lost 90 over 90
almost 99 of its stock value in the
dot-com bubble burst
and he could have easily just like moved
on to something else but he just built
it all up again and then the question is
like why
like if you're already the richest
person in the world what is compelling
and he's not bill gates going to you
know cure malaria or something
he just like can't stop trying to play
out
his thesis about like where tech is
going
and i think that is really confusing for
a lot of investors who whatever they say
are ultimately like money driven